you seem a little preoccupied today a
little like something's on your mind
something's bothering you
it's true it's just that it makes me mad
that it feels like everyone is really
mean to Kanye West and it just I'm sick
of it I've had it up to here and it's
like become like the popular thing to
like pile on Kanye Oh everyone can agree
Kanye is an [ __ ] hahaha and I don't
agree you don't you don't agree well I
do agree that he is an [ __ ] that he's
not talented yes could people put those
together and they are wrong he actually
is really talented Jesus is like the
best album out there it's a smaller
group because they're like no I'm gonna
sit on my applause because he's such an
a-hole
I won't applaud big but there it is you
know there it is because he's a
narcissist yes I've thought a lot about
this you clearly had a narcissism that
kind of ruins the thing for people's
thing they're like he's cuz he says he's
the best they're like a few then if you
say you're the best that I'm gonna hate
your art yeah that's all I have to say
I need to down the dose